(brouhaha)
- C'est la plus ancienne
école primaire et secondaire
de Kaboul.
(récitation)
Le lycée Malalaï a vu défiler,
au cours du siècle dernier,
des élèves qui allaient,
pour certains, former
l'élite de la société afghane.
- Bonjour, les élèves!
- (élèves): Bonjour, Madame!
- Dans cette classe de 6e année,
des filles de 10 à 14 ans
apprennent les rudiments
du français.
- L'après-midi...
(indistinct)
- La professeure fait
quelques fautes, mais on peut
difficilement lui en vouloir.
- "Ma" cheveu est court.
- (élèves): "Ma" cheveu
est court.
- C'est que Hassina n'a
que 16 ans et elle n'est pas
enseignante. Après la prise
de pouvoir des talibans,
le lycée a perdu tous
ses professeurs de français.
Et comme pour toutes les filles
afghanes au-delà de la 6e année,
les talibans ont décidé que
Hassina n'a plus le droit de
fréquenter les bancs d'école.
- (élèves): Les yeux marrons.
- Au premier rang de la classe,
on remarque tout de suite
l'engouement de Nadia et Hadia.
Tour à tour, elles lèvent
la main bien haut pour
prendre part aux exercices.
- Euh... oui.
- (professeure): Vanne.
- Vanne.
- Elles n'ont pas l'intention de
s'effacer derrire les garçons.
- L'une rêve de devenir juge;
l'autre veut être médecin.
- Merci, bravo!
- Une aspiration noble
de servir son pays.
Mais l'an prochain,
elles seront trop grandes
pour rester à l'école.
Pour Raihana, l'exclusion
forcée des salles de classe
est une double punition.
Elle n'ose même plus
jouer ses morceaux favoris
sur le clavier qu'elle a
à la maison.
Dunya, sa copine, se sent
elle aussi réduite au silence.
Cette douleur dont elle parle,
elle a été décuplée depuis
l'arrivée au pouvoir des
talibans. Mais Raihana insiste,
ce n'est pas de la peur.
Des paroles assumées,
répétées comme un mantra
auquel s'accrocher et qui
rendent Jholyia très fière.
Cette enseignante féministe
cumulait deux postes à temps
complet pour subvenir
aux besoins de sa famille;
deux emplois qu'elle a perdus.
Ces droits pour lesquels
elle veut continuer de se
battre, ils ont été durement
acquis par les femmes au cours
des 20 dernières années par
le biais d'une multitude
de programmes d'aide
au développement financés par
la communauté internationale.
C'était l'ultime priorité
du Canada, mais comme
les emplois de Jholya,
ces programmes disparaissent
avec l'arrivée de talibans.
Il y a une semaine déjà,
les talibans continuaient
de dire que les filles plus
âgées pourraient retourner
à l'école... bientôt.
Il faut d'abord pouvoir
assurer leur sécurité et
mettre en place une ségrégation
des sexes absolue.
Au lycée Malalaï, la directrice
reste confiante que les talibans
respecteront leur parole.
(chant)
L'espoir, c'est un mot
qu'on prononce très peu
en Afghanistan, sauf pour dire
qu'il n'en reste presque plu